schwer bewaffnet schwer gepanzert
riesenradjahr in Niedersachsen
Großeinsatz für die Polizei in
Friedenberg
idyllisch gelegen ruhig und von Feldern
umschlossen das ändert sich am
Donnerstagmorgen gegen 6 Uhr
Ziel des Einsatzes war ein 36-jähriger
Mann Mammut C der mit einer Bande von 12
Personen seit 2020 Diebstahl im ganz
großen Stil begangen haben soll ihm wird
zur Last gelegt mit mehreren Komplizen
aus dem Chemiewerk Aurubis einen
Hamburger Unternehmen über mehrere Jahre
kupferreste und edelmetallreste aus dem
Werk geschleust zu haben und so einen
Betrag von über 20 Millionen Euro
erbeutet zu haben
vor dem Einsatz waren nicht bekannt was
die Polizei erwartet das Areal
weitläufig das Anwesen mit hohen Hecken
umschlossen daher das Großaufgebot mit
Fahrzeugen und Einsatzkräften
vorneweg der Polizei Panzerwagen
Survivor
diese Durchsuchung war nicht die einzige
am Donnerstagmorgen fahren dadurch
suchten 30 Objekte darunter Wohnungen
Geschäfte Bankschließfächer in Hamburg
Hessen Niedersachsen Schleswig-Holstein
und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern die Polizei
verhaftet bei den Einsätzen sechs
Personen insgesamt wird gegen 12
Tatverdächtige ermittelt bei dieser
riesen Razzia gegen das organisierte
Verbrechen
[Musik]